okay these so-called non Dom's like Lord
Rothermere avoid more than 4 billion
pounds tax per year hello mate I just
wanted this Lord rough me live here
please I'd love to speak to Lord roth me
yay say it's Russell Brand to speak to
Lord Rothermere say it's about living
here and taxis you can acquire a dollar
soil you can also lose it hello okay I
just wanted to ask if Lord Rothermere
lives here does he pay his taxes in
England do you know oh yeah I don't know
either like if he's domiciled here he
should pay taxes here I just wondered
wonder he paying Heron tax on the 1.5
billion when he inherit the Daily Mail
fees dad whose name was also Lord
Rothermere by coincidence and also if
it's true that he runs the Daily Mail
out of Bermuda which is a tax haven and
controls it from Jersey which is also a
tax haven hello Lord Roth Mia but Roth
near
Jersey where Rob me rides his cash has
400 billion dollars of assets in trusts
as part of the austerity cuts this
government introduced a so-called
bedroom tax it affects half a million
people if non doms like Rothermere paid
their tax then we wouldn't need a
bedroom tax at all
you